and you and I sat surrounded by Broken
Glass smoking these cigars and drinking
Guinness do you remember at the top of
Grafton Street and the thing you said
and I agreed with you said you know myth
and story is just the best way to talk
about almost everything it's the
indigenous way to talk about everything
it's the classical way to talk about
everything it's the Aran way it's the
it's the Irish way it's the Russian way
it's the Aboriginal way it's what we've
always done there's a very old notion
I'm interested in which is human beings
get made it's actually a process and if
you don't have connection to stories
rather like a cloak then you are prone
to enormous floods of anxiety as you get
older as you experience the duress of
Life despite all the gadgetry if we
don't have this very ancient technology
called a story close to hand we're
unequipped in some way
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic
[Applause]
world so hello everyone I am Overjoyed
to be with Martin Shaw again he is
Martin has been on my channel before
we've done some events in Ireland and in
England he is a mythographer professor
at Stanford uh wonderful writer amazing
Storyteller and he is going to be one of
the headline speakers for the symbolic
World Summit so I'm really excited to be
able to continue our our exchanges and
so Martin thanks for thanks for coming
on oh Jonathan delighted to be here and
very much looking forward to Florida in
February and so Martin you are are a
Storyteller in ways that is difficult
for modern people to understand so this
is something that I also at first didn't
totally grasp and in meeting you I
started to understand it which is that
you are one of the few people I don't
know left in the world not many people
that tell stories over sometimes days
you know like hours and then sometimes
days and you are getting ready now to
give a version of The Odyssey yeah
that's true Jonathan I'm going to be
telling the truncated version from
Friday night through to Sunday afternoon
really without a breath that's the
synopsis that's synopsis uh so I'll
report back to you how that went I
haven't told it since before lockdown So
Stories from a Bic perspective they are
erasable animate beings and they require
a kind of courtship if you're going to
tell them they're not just repertoire
they're not just going to show up and so
I found that for the first couple of
weeks The Odyssey simply didn't want to
be remembered by me it had gone into a
huff it had gone to the back of uh
polyphemus's Cave and wouldn't come out
so you just have to sit there with a
story and show Fidelity to it until
finally it says okay let's try this out
but as you will know through our time
together I don't tell stories in a kind
of recital manner it's very much
imagining out loud so um
that interest in spontaneity that
interest in trafficking in Wild thoughts
that was kind of what got me into this
in the first place yeah yeah but so
there's a kind of a I guess there's a
mix between getting the basic let's take
the basic structure of the story right
you know you know you have the element
that you can't transgress that and then
weaving through that with a with a kind
of
improvisation think of it like a recipe
that's been passed down through a family
and no one is meant to mess with the
recipe and for the first hundred times
you cook it you cook it exactly as your
aunt told you to do but on cook up uh
101 you discover smoked paprika and you
don't know if you're a new about smok
paprika or not but you can add that
little thing it's to do with what they
call the sense and the matter of Stories
the matter of the story is what you just
described it's the A to B to C but the
sense of the story is the genius in it
and it's it's why three people could
turn up and tell the handless maiden but
there'd be one telling that you would
energetically you'd lean you'd lean to
them rather than all three it's not a
sort of generic handout storytellers are
odd figures who have usually been hurt
by the world early on and to make sense
of of a cosmos where most mythology is
lying in pieces around our ankles
stories are sense making devices you
know their codes of of a fashion well
the Odyssey I know when I told the
ancient stories to my kids The Odyssey
was the one that just stuck to them my
daughter when she was 11 years old or
maybe even I think around maybe even
younger like 10 11 she memorized the ABC
of the Odyssey she knew all the sections
she didn't know I mean she didn't
memorize the story but she she could
tell you what all the narrative elements
were and she she did it one time at a
campfire where she just kind of
enumerated the new the the uh the
narrative elements at least of the story
uh and so I was really surprised at just
how much it stuck and so now and you're
rereading it and sitting with it what
insights have you come out have come out
of that that time well is a strong one
uh if you were a Mediterranean Warrior
from 3,000 years ago you lived in what I
would call a Clos culture not chaos Clos
now Clos means imperishable Glory it
means your reputation that lives on once
you're gone and you remember to a
Mediterranean Warrior that's not heaven
you're going to it's this far more am
ambivalent
underworld so you want your reputation
to exist longer than you but here's the
rub about Clos Clos is in entirely
dependent on external validation you
can't give yourself Clos your sense of
inner nobl it doesn't matter it doesn't
really matter there is no you in the way
that modern people think about it it is
all about how other people look at you
so as I come to telling it again I
realize we're living in another age of
Clos and our screens which are the
temples that we now generally serve in
and our mirrors which we are entranced
in like
narcissus we've
replaced we've we've replaced what I
we've replaced shelter with Comfort
religious shelter to spiritual comfort
we have a kind of uh alakat attitude
towards you know cosmological spiritual
religious issues and we just pick and
choose what we want so that's been the
strange thing and it often happens with
the story
there's a reason why the Odyssey has now
been remembered an active Act of
remembering for what 2800 years
something like that it's because the
Odyssey is happening every day the
issues that are going on in it are Hardy
perennials they don't go away so the
Clos thing has been big for
me and so when you say that we that that
we live in this new age of Clos you mean
in terms of the say the likes and the
the the kind of this this kind of outer
approbation of our of our of our
existence let's say like we need to we
need to be seen by the world we need to
show ourselves on Instagram and to to
have that kind of is that is that what
you mean yeah yeah it's a kind of anti
John of the Cross it's an anti- still
Small Voice these days if we even get in
touch with our still Small Small Voice
we may be getting fake news from our own
psyche because we because we don't tell
stories anymore we don't actually do it
in the jaw what they call the me Hall of
the jaw then stories remain as there's a
poet called Friedrich haland and he says
Gods be careful you have become
decorations in their poems and the
reason it's good to tell stories orally
is the stories stop becoming decorative
or witty they bring their troubles right
to your door and they start to do the
work that can only be told when you you
actually involve it so kudos to your
daughter kudos to my daughter who when
she was about eight knew all of wolf ran
Ving back's paral and I implore
everybody I'm so thrilled with what's
going on with symbolic world and this
whole network that's happening YouTube
has become a really interesting
place my my one petition would be that
when people study a story with you they
go away in small groups and tell it to
each other just try it out take a risk
maybe there are myth tellers amongst you
that's an interesting idea we're doing
now a kind of intense reading of baywolf
with Richard Roland uh and it's and it's
really insightful because it's something
like a Christian reading of B trying to
help people see the Christian cosmology
that a lot of the scholars actually
can't see because they don't know the
Book of Enoch and all these weird
traditions in Christianity um but it's a
good idea to then maybe take that and be
able and and then retell baywolf I I
used to do it too I I actually memorize
the elements of baywolf and would tell
it like at at the campfire we we we'd
have this these storytelling at the
campfire try to kind of get into the the
story yeah I I I'm by the way I'm very
interested that you and Richard and
thank you for introducing me to
Richard's work the man has a a mind as
big as a prairie he's fantastic and the
two of you together wow from next week
on substack all the way to Christmas I
am telling the Icelandic Saga of King
kol kraki which is the dark twin of
bearwolf it's it's darker than bearwolf
okay uh just as a just as a uh just in
case people were wondering what paganism
really look
like if voila there you go and that so
that's but that's an Insight that you
just before we started recording you
mentioned something about that you said
that you feel like the world is becoming
Pagan again but with some differences I
think the world is turning the world has
to turn Pagan because
atheism atheism is simply too depressing
and I think the argument of rationality
and in uh rationality and irrationality
that's been a big religious argument
over the last 100 years I think to some
degree we're past that now I think
people are aware we all serve some kind
of Temple and wherever we put our
attention for any of time if we look at
it in a certain way we afford it enough
significance it becomes holy to us
that's what happens but I think we are
becoming Pagan but
without without the influence of the
Olympians without the
wisdom uh of those you know um those
beings that direct and inform those
stories uh so I'm not advocating for it
but Clos is a pagan response to the
world Clos is a pagan response to the
world imperishable glory is what was
going on in Greek and Roman myth
therefore I see through you know being a
father and having a teenage daughter
what is coming at her in endlessly
through social media is an attempt to
create just that kind of thing
yeah one of the things that I've been
thinking about in terms of the Odyssey
you know I I've been thinking that it is
very appropr to this time now because
the Odyssey is this desire to return
home you know the the sense of being a
drift being kind of you know moving
around without without having an anchor
and and you know encountering all these
strange principalities and the strange
women and all of this all of this stuff
but then with this desire to kind of
return home to to the Hearth and so it
feels like it's an appropriate it's an
appropriate story to tell today because
we all seem to feel that we have this we
feel alienated we feel like we don't
have a place to stand and that we don't
even know where to look at least for now
where to look to find that home again
yeah now you and I coming from an
orthodox background would have the same
take on that probably that CS Lewis did
which is you're really that nostos
that's the word the yearning that adius
has for itha is nostos in Welsh it's
called hith it's this it's homecoming
but it's more than homecoming Lewis
sensed it when he used to experience
what he in Tolen called northernness
it's a feeling it's it's a it's a
feeling the yans would call it anima
possession but that's a grotesque phrase
so forget I ever said it animal
possession but the point of it is uh
yeah from an orthodox perspective from a
Christian perspective that is the Divine
World starting to radiate through this
one and and call to you but um it's
interesting because you will know before
you know the other great text from Homer
is The Iliad Now The Iliad is not a
story of nostos it is a story of War
it's a story of a great conflict in the
great hero of that era Achilles and
achilles has the choice of because his
mother is a a goddess he knows things
about his life he should not know and
one of the things he knows is he has a
choice do I want a small life filled
with Clos or do I want a long life but
absolutely obscure and he goes down the
James Dean Jimmy Hendrick dead at 28
route you know yeah yeah but um but I'm
fascinated by this because in now the
the first time we met we ended up
talking about the Odyssey and mid
conversation with you I had a thought
that I will now repeat because it's
significance to me I think in The
Odyssey we hear an echo of the arrival
of Christ of
foreshadowing and the reason why is it's
when adius goes to the underworld and he
bumps into Achilles who does not have
good words for him but he asks Achilles
how's this Clos working out for you down
here in the dark and and achilles
says sooner be a slave to a poor man
than King of the underworld now that is
that is an antios move and as far as I
can tell the Beatitudes The Sermon on
the Mount the sheer weird aido
countercultural moves of Christ turn all
of that on its head you're hearing what
18800 years or something no 800 really I
suppose with Homer before Christ you're
hearing the end of one age and the
beginning of another what's so
mindblowing for me is you know capernum
was on a trade route so it's possible
that a you know can you imagine the
Jewish boy is hearing some of these
stories not as the Odyssey but he might
have heard fragments of them I'm not
saying they influenced him it's just a
mindboggling thought yeah to think that
that would be part of the same kind of
Storytelling world I've also seen in in
odius when odius returns home and he he
dresses as a as a beggar basically as a
as a beggar and then he with he wants it
seems like he wants his son to recognize
him through he wants the people that he
loves to recognize him possibly through
the the disguise or or or he's using the
disguise to get back into to the house
there's something about that also about
Christ who who comes as who is this King
who's hiding in the in the lowest the
lowest image you could say I don't know
if you've ever thought about that yeah
more so recently than before you know
the last time I told this story I was a
screaming Pagan romantic so a few things
have changed in the last 5 years one
thing I'd say though is all of the
trouble that odys gets into is because
of when he blinds the Cyclops the
Cyclops says to him who did this and
adicus can't bear leaving without
announcing his achievement and when he
says that the cyclops's father Poseidon
says right I've got a zip code for
edicius now he's done
and again in a reversal of Clos yeah the
only way adicus can return to Ithaca he
leaves as somebody and he returns as
nobody and it's only through that shift
does he finally display that wonderful
word metis his particular wit his
particular cunning to get through being
contact with his son tacus speak to
Penelope and then all the Mayhem that
then goes on but that Christ connection
is is really interesting yeah well I
mean it's interesting in the sense but
obviously Christ didn't have that other
part and you can see that in you can see
that in Christ you see the opposite
which is it's interesting because Christ
hides his divinity during the story he
actually he always says people and heals
people and says don't tell anyone you
know you know don't tell anyone what I
did this weird this and it it's only as
he gets closer to his crucifixion and
it's in the moment when he's basically
been beaten you know he's been tortured
he's bloody and he's standing there in
front of the the judges in front of the
the Sedin and then he says you know like
I'm that I'm the son of man basically
it's like and you know the high priest
rips his vestment but it's like in that
it's it's almost like a very different
than the story of adicus which is that
first he hides it and when he reveals it
it's in the worst possible moment it's
like it's in the moment where you're a
prisoner and you've been completely
humiliated and now you say I am the son
of son of man it's it's a wild it's a
wild reversal yes and it's why as a
mythologist I just avoided my my root
system I avoided Christ for 50 years
because he was nonsensical to me it's
not difficult for me to fall into a kind
of biological resonance with the great
Heroes of the earlier story stories but
Christ is a much more thin skinned
pressurized kind of individual do you
know it's funny because I'm a
Storyteller whenever Christ says don't
tell anybody in my mind in a fairy tale
whenever you say don't do that it means
who that uh now I don't think that's
what he meant but I I always smile at
those moments because there's nothing
more that will be quickly
disclosed you know that's a that's an
interesting point to think about like it
could be part of the the some of the
deep ironies that Christ manifest you
know like there they they appear
especially in the crucifixion but there
are these deep deep ironies in his story
where you know he he he's humiliated but
is treated like a king at the same time
so it's possible that when he says that
he's it's almost like he's saying you
know here's a seed you know keep it keep
it safe and then it grows and it starts
to grow and it starts to to you know I
mean this is this is very much your
bread and butter you know your your
bread and beer in terms of what you love
but the the shock of coming to the Bible
profoundly in middle age and recognizing
it's this kind of echo chamber where
everything is talking to everything else
all the time and nothing is wasted
there's not a line in the book I can
find that is wasted now there are things
I struggle with
constant I think you're supposed to I I
I think that there's something about
scripture which makes it that there are
some St it's like you you can see
exactly what you said you can see all of
these things connecting and you can
notice that there's this giant web of
references that are that are going
backwards and forwards and so you you
trust it but then you come to some bit
where you know in the Book of Judges the
man who cuts his his his uh his mistress
into pieces and sends it off to the
tribe it's like there are some bits that
are so crazy and and you know that this
probably is hiding a very deep meaning
because everything else is but you can't
you can't catch it you know it's painful
no and I think as modern people we're
wired to like or dislike characters we
like strong signals about who's good
who's bad what's going on and then the
Bible has these stories where supposedly
good people suddenly do very strange uh
things know David is one of them uh I'm
telling this story uh The Saga of King
hulf kraki right through the Autumn this
deep Icelandic tale there's no comedy
value none in fact in the sagas if
there's too much comedy in you can be
sure that that is a a continental
influence that's not that's not how the
schools would have told it but there's
this one character called halty the
magnanimous who lives in a bone p he's
the only guy remotely approachable the
rest of them are just Berserkers and
then just as you're starting to like him
he bites his girlfriend's nose off in an
argument and continues talking to
her crunching up her nose and saying
well you
know I I think this is I think this is
it for me and you I'm just not feeling
it
anymore and and my heart sunk at that
moment because I thought halty the
magnanimous was all I had you know he
was my only moment of warmth in this
this this thing and so the Bible can be
like that for me and the the
way you know I I I find it an act of
will sometimes to remember the Bible
it's as if the stories they sort of test
you they almost want you to forget them
they want you to remember
them I'm just improvising this as I'm
saying that to learn a story from the
Bible is like when I'm in Divine Liturgy
and father borius serves me that bit of
bread soaked in wine that looks all all
to the world like a piece of meat you
know all to the world like a piece of
meat and I'm suddenly in this kind of
living iconography you know I'm changed
it's amazing I don't do you experience
this at liturgy I eat the bread this
tiny bit of bread and I am no longer
hungry MH I noticed this again and again
I'm always hungry obviously I've been
fasting since Vespers and I get in there
and I eat and I this tiny thing but
because of what is what it is it is
subsumed in it has this miraculous
effect yeah in the story of the Saints
you have that you have story crazy
stories of saints that live only from
the Eucharist wow I didn't know that's
all they eat yeah there there are some
wild stories sometimes it's like once a
year or something like some really crazy
story about eating the ugas once a year
and surviving
all through but there's it what you said
about the scripture there's something
there's something about the scripture
stories
which it's also because they've been so
glossed that sometimes we kind of see
them through the gloss which is not bad
because the raw stories are sometimes a
little too much to deal with but uh you
can actually read all the Bible stories
from multiple points of view very much
like you could read The Iliad and and
you know sympathize with the the Trojans
and so you can try to read the story so
I you know read the story of Abraham and
real and read as if Abraham is not the
not a hero at all and you'll see that
the the story will tell itself and will
make sense and you can do the opposite
so there's this weird thing about the
story and it's very algebraic that's why
it's difficult to remember because a lot
of the more ancient types of epics they
have descriptions and they'll have
they'll be like these poetic types of uh
you know description of emotion there's
none of that in the Bible the Bible is
just like this happened this happened
this happened this happened you know and
so it's more difficult to but once you
see the pattern you realize how powerful
it is it just takes more at least for
our minds to pierce them yes and you
have to be careful because once if you
are a chapter and verse Christian and
you have so sort of calcified your
imagination to the point where that is
the only legitimate way those stories
are can be can be told or even chanted
in our tradition not even told God
forbid the intonation of your own voice
and expression could come into it you
know this is Martin Luther territory uh
so so it that has been a struggle for me
is how far in I mean the great the great
way in recently has been I've been
telling and will be continuing to tell
the story of Joseph in Egypt as an
underworld descent story Joseph in the
Underworld I've been telling the story
of job as the opening of what I call the
Wonder ey where actually I think
although we think we're loaded up with
questions for God of course in that
story in the end God doesn't answer any
of job's questions but he does say come
have a look behind the veil for five
minutes and then let's see then let's
see how chat you are um so I'm F I'm
finding my way into it I'm thinking a
lot about the story of Samson at the
moment and others so it's working but um
you're he
take oh man this story of Samson is it
is some I think one of the church
fathers said that the story of Samson is
the closest story to Christ in the Old
Testament uh and that's a that's a but
you have to just see it through the
right lens which is Samson is trying to
join with the stranger that's what
Samson is trying to do and so he's this
weird character that is moving towards
he's trying to join the margin and the
center right he takes the door and
brings it up to the top of the hill
that's basically what Samson is trying
to do but he keeps messing it up right
he finds he finds honey in the dead line
that's what Samson is right but it's
like but at the same time he he can't
hold it
together and then he has to he has to
kill
himself that's in the the the the the
honey in the lion just as the the the
sheer unintellectual power of that image
there's got to be a Christian group
called Lion's Hunter or something it
just it just begs it just begs for it
but it's it's I mean I I came into
stories and I came into myth when I
would have been in my early 20s I'd L
them when I was
younger but I ended up living in a tent
for four years I don't know if we've
ever talked about this I ended up it
became important to me in the late 90s
when I would have been in my mid-20s to
see if there were any real pockets of
British wilderness left so I took off in
a black tent without a phone or a
computer and effectively to the outside
well to some degree disappeared for four
years and I
just wanted to be absolutely
undomesticated I wanted to find what
there's an Irish philosopher John
moratti calls it your bush soul and so
when I went through that experience I
found the best way to talk about it
without the use of eye statements was
these old stories you and I we were once
in you and I once went walking in Dublin
late at night and every single person we
passed was hurling bottles around I
don't you remember they just bottles
smashing the whole the whole town was in
what you call shamini says we are
approaching Jubilation they hadn't got
to Jubilation but they were approaching
it and you and I sat surrounded by
broken glass smoking these cigars and
drinking Guinness do you
remember at the top of Grafton Street
and the thing you said and I agreed with
you said you know myth and story is just
the best way to talk about almost
everything it's the indigenous way to
talk about everything it's the classical
way to talk about everything it's the
aruan way it's the it's the Irish way
it's the Russian way it's the Aboriginal
way it's what we've always done in the
there's there's a very old notion I'm
interested in which is we don't human
beings get made it's actually a process
and if you don't have connection to
stories rather like a
cloak then you are prone to enormous
floods of anxiety as you get older as
you experience the duress of Life
despite all the gadgetry if we don't
have this very ancient technology called
a story close to hand we're unequipped
in some way yeah yeah I I think that
there there's something so if you think
of something like an ethical code for
example right a series of that's fine we
need those you know that they they're
important but a story is like a tuning
fork you know it what it it kind of
vibrates and you start to vibrate with
it and you can actually be transformed
without understanding anything without
knowing why it's happening without
without having any rational explanation
for why it is you're being transformed
because because because you're actually
you're identifying with the characters
you're you're or you're or you're not
identifying with the characters and
that's putting you in a space where
you're basically it's more like music
you know you're more vibrating with the
with the pattern and then at some point
without knowing it you find that your
perspective has been transformed yeah
and now what's going to H on that
thought what's going to happen in a few
hours in my life is I'm going to get 70
people responding getting tuned at
different polyphonic parts of the story
of adicus not just one part but many
it's a little bit like watching someone
having acupuncture and they go I'm not
feeling much here don't feel anything
there don't oh my God that that's that's
where it is that's where the trouble is
now the thing that turns a myth from a
reenactment fair or a seance into
something that's actually happening in
the room now a living myth is exactly
that proximity to wonder that proximity
to the story doing its cathon work on
you before you've had someone allegorize
it to death or tell you what it means
one of the things that I liked about the
Exodus series that you did with Jordan
and our mutual friend James or and
others is that I was impressed at how
much pandemonium intellectual
pandemonium was going on I was so
pleased that that hadn't all been cut
out and we just had the bits where you
were all concurring and agreeing and
nodding sagely it was kind of messy yeah
and that really is its Saving Grace we
you and I and maybe Jordan and a few we
should do one on on the Odyssey oh yeah
just putting it out there you know of
enor if you want to understand how we in
the west tick you cannot not get there
without stories like the Odyssey yeah
that's a great idea to do a reading of
the Odyssey and to kind of get go
through the the images I would love to
do that we should definitely organize it
tell me about the conference so okay so
the I'm gonna speak of this don't know
what I know what the means you know and
so I've been doing this now for what uh
seven years I guess since 2016 slowly
building up a a let's say helping
hopefully helping people see the world
differently I would say that's the thing
that I've been doing you know also in
line with some of the things my brother
has been doing as well and now what i'
what I've noticed is that there are
people that have been able to transform
their thinking and it's impressive to
what extent they have been and I find
always surprised because for for a large
part of my life I felt like I was a
freak that I was a freak that thought in
a very strange way and that nobody could
understand and now all of a sudden there
are these people that are that are
thinking this way it's transforming
their their they're thinking so the idea
is to meet in person you really it's to
to instead of just doing this online
thing to actually come into the same
space you know to to to meet each other
and also to participate in there'll be
different streams there'll be there'll
be a artistic Stream So artists will
have a chance to meet each other
exchange about their work look at how
they can you know use this kind of
mythical thinking in their work there'll
be one which is more like the home how
to include these this way of living in
your home symbolic living symbolic
thinking in your home life um and then
there'll be obviously the universal
history path which is you know people
moving closer to how to reinterpret
history in a way that that connects it
with myth uh and then you know realizing
that myth is the driving power of
History to be honest that without the
myth behind the history you know we
don't care about these stories like the
H the ba the boring historical things
have no no spark if they're not anchored
in something that is transcendent or
something that you that you can care
about that's why all the ancient people
would connect their story to Troy and to
and to the Bible you it's like they they
had to connect to the ancient Mythic
past so basically we're going to be
there there there'll be some music you
know and then obviously there'll be
there'll be you speaking we'll have
discussions there'll be father Steven D
Young Who I don't know if you've heard
some of his yeah he's amazing yeah so I
I just feel like even just having the
the the three of us together is going to
be pretty explosive uh but then having
all the people there it's gonna be great
well it is and I've also seen you know
you've got Vesper Stamper you've got n
you got you know Kar Richard Roland Neil
de grade like yeah they're all I mean
this is this is I go you know I buy a
ticket for this I'd be in the audience
if I wasn't on the stage for sure man
yeah so know I'm really looking forward
to it and uh and in some ways you know I
think that this you know rediscovering
these ancient way of thinking and and
and living that's the key to the Future
it's it's not easy to connect it to the
modern world sometimes it's it's
difficult to know how to deal with the
technological world and kind of want to
go back into this mythical world uh but
we have to work through it right we have
to we have to find a way to connect them
together or else or else we're going to
lose ourselves so we are and and I think
I think you know of course from a
distance everything looks different from
a distance you know a lot when I try and
explain to my friends that I'm an
Eastern Orthodox Christian a Russian
Orthodox Christian right now that's not
a popular look in Europe I can assure
you uh but from the it looks like one
thing from the outside just looks like
these odd shaped bble onions and strange
looking things and everybody's standing
up and what's going on but you get in
there you get inside and it's nothing to
do with a long time ago that's one of
the great secrets of myth myth when it
is functioning efficiently is not really
to do with a long time ago those stories
do not get remembered the stories that
get remembered are the ones the day that
was not like the day before and when you
didn't have endless iPads or even
literacy you had to decide what am I
going to choose to remember it was a
conscious Act of Will and as you were
saying a few minutes ago stories like
the tuning fork um they do something to
you I'm very interested in the notion uh
of nobless obl which really translates
as if you are noble you have to act
Noble and to act Noble you really need
to be around stories that externally
show you through symbolic images what
that looks like uh and without consuming
that that uh it's very hard to stay
focused on it and so you've been you've
been on a path like a bath of massive
transformation you know in your own
personal life then obviously also even I
imagine even your readers there's been
change in that world like who who is who
is coming none of them left who's who's
coming to the workshops all of that and
so I'm I'm curious to see you know your
the change of your perspective and how
it has changed your vision of
storytelling do you feel like the way
that you see stories or that you engage
with stories that changed in the past
few years yeah and I think I can sum it
up pretty quickly actually I would say
uh and I'm moving between a sort of a
Mythic and a religious perspective and
there's almost no difference in the in
the world that I live
in myth showed me everything I needed to
know about the conditions of living
different gods and goddesses show show
you the betrayals the healings the
strange nuances to it all it shows you
the playing field it's
phenomenal how to live it was the
missing element for me and that I have
to say is the Christian narrative it's
the Christian story because it's so it
actually turns a lot of the myths before
it kind of on its head because of
this last you'll be first antios kind of
thing going on this huge enormous
Consciousness where we're not just
venerating trees and bends in the river
and all the thousands and millions of
little Elohim and Messengers that are
moving around us we're making a claim
that we're in contact with the being
that is infused in that but also
completely outside of it as
well I that was just kind of too big for
me
uh but in the absence of that my life I
suppose up until you know up until a few
years ago had the familiar kind of
chaotic fault lines of not having that
essential kind of binding agent uh that
is Yeshua so a lot A lot has changed
it's not as if my life hasn't been
nourished and informed and blessed
beyond measure by these stories but the
reality is
and this is hard this a lot of
Christians don't like me saying what I'm
about to say the reality is you know I
I'm with Augustine all truth is God's
truth yeah and I think that a lot of
these stories that could be some story
way up from the in it and and they and I
respect this they may not want to see it
in this way but from my point of view
many myths and stories are filled with
pin Pricks and hints of this great
story and so I feel that I was on a kind
of drip feed for a really long time and
the thing that my heart was swooning for
over and over in these stories was
something that I could never depend in
defend in public but was actually this
sort of
terrifying Revelation that actually it
was the it was the you know the aan of
my youth wishing to anounce itself and I
ended up I went on a vigil for 101 days
I went out into a dartmore forest and at
the end of it uh I had a
profoundly uh
eviscerating
beautiful uh unimaginable almost
encounter with Christ but in the one
place I never expected to meet him I
went out there thinking well by the time
I finished this I'll probably be married
to the wild in some way and I came back
married to Christ and I realized that
both both of these these weddings are
facing each other it's a strange thing
to say as someone I'm not a classicist
we're talking about the Odyssey I'm not
a classicist um in England if you're a
classicist that's kind of connected to a
class
system really connected to a certain
level of school that you would have gone
to I didn't go to schools like that but
I have a real
experience understanding and many
decades long involvement with uh
indigenous and shamanic stories oddly
then much much closer to Christ figures
than ones that you get in the west they
understand very well the idea of the
suffering healer they understand very
well the one that you're not looking at
is the one that is actually kind of
binding and through an act of love and
sacrifice bringing new life to the tribe
so I was I was aware of these things but
now of course I see the for
example I see you know the crucifixion
as the Supreme poetic event of of human
experience but I I it was as if I was
just not allowed to see it until I was
almost 50 it was like this and then God
said and
now now and and for the last two years
my jobian Wonder ey has been opened but
for some reason he wanted me to get all
this other stuff in me too and so I'm in
this thrilling and unexpected M you know
what midlife is like you can feel like
you've seen all the movies worth
possibly seeing so to be in this new
world where I'm meeting um I like what
Paul Vander Clay is doing you know he's
a very interesting man with all his sort
of cross associations you see I come my
dad is a preacher my brother is a pastor
I'm very familiar with all of this but
at the same time because of Orthodoxy
I've been opened up
to I grew up in church all the action
was in the Pulpit now the actions in the
Liturgy you know the pulpit is the only
moment it's the the sermon is the only
moment where you can sit down he's like
yeah yeah okay sit down this is just me
for five minutes and now everybody you
know stand orai wisdom and we're off you
know so I I kind of know where I am but
I also don't know where I am which is a
wonderful place to be and I think that
with you said you know the idea that in
some ways you had to pack all this other
all this other stuff in you I think in
some ways you know this might will seem
a little maybe I'm pushing it and
whatever whatever people think but that
it seems like to me that's the role that
I perceive that you can have right now
now in this moment which is you know you
use the word the word reing
Christianity there are different ways to
say it but there is something in the O
other myths which in the shamanic
stories in the these ancient myths which
can can help us see the story of the
Bible aresh again because in some ways
it's giving you tax and it's giving you
ways into it that a lot of people have
glossed over through their kind of
systematic theology you know like this
is this leads to this it leads to this
and Jesus has died for your sins and if
you believe in him you go to heaven you
know that kind of stuff where it's like
you've actually stopped looking at the
at the crazy things that Jesus does and
the crazy things that that are in those
stories you you will be aware and I
think we have to kind of uh certainly in
this in England we have to do our caps
to Tom Holland the writer in his book
Dominion Tom was the first guy that was
saying actually despite the propaganda
England and the West in general is
profoundly christianized now I go along
with that for a while but the problem is
we are christianized civically and
culturally we're not spiritually anymore
we're not this is not a Christian
culture and so the Cross isn't quite we
got that bit but we haven't got that bit
uh so I love the fact that he yourself
Paul Kings North lots of others are
talking about the fact that we have we
can't be taking our cues from a culture
that doesn't give a about us
anymore because we just get more and
more thinned out diluted apologetic
we're sort of you know don't look at me
don't look at me you know uh whereas
actually people I meet people all over
the world looking for a Deeper Life and
the more we take our cues nervously from
a culture that at best has Amnesia if
not active hostility to these stories
the better but we need to retell
them
not not uh antha tize them or put in
little cues to make them politically
correct forget that we just and need
them in their pure genius raw form to be
to do their work to let God do his work
you know uh I think something's
happening I have to say it I think
something's happening I've never born in
the early 70s I've never seen a moment
quite as pregnant as this one I've never
known so many people talking about
things like this I think you're right
you know I think that the way that I see
it is something like a like an arc you
know it's like we're we're actually
there's a contraction of Christianity
but in that contraction the people that
care about it have to do it so
deliberately that it cannot be
accidental anymore it can't just be
something we're surfing it just can't be
so we have to look into it deeply we
have to we we don't have a choice and so
because of it it creates this weird
little this this this this smaller but
brighter group of people that are can
see each other and are you know I'm
amazed like you said like you know if
you would asked me to predict Paul Kings
North and Martin Shaw you know five six
years ago I could not have predicted it
but then when I see when I see that
coming over the horizon
I'm like yes that that that's that's it
like and I can see that like you said I
can see things coming together uh and so
it's exciting I mean what what other
life would you want to lead it's
exciting to be to be in a world that is
semih hostile to you but then being
surrounded by a round table of amazing
nights is like what else would I want
yeah yeah I think I think we're all in
agreement that church needs to be
Camelot again you know I think really
and if people people don't think we're
in a moment of tremendous Peril they are
simply not paying attention they're not
paying attention all the ingredients you
want for a phenomenal myth are occurring
in real time right now you don't need to
be nostalgic you didn't miss out there
was no other golden age of myth that was
more more engaging than this this is the
moment and so find your place at the
table and I say that to everybody
there'll be some kid right now watching
us on a phone doing some shift you know
his third shift at McDonald's we're
talking to you you know we're talking to
you Lo locate locate that no bless obl
in you and see what kind of trouble you
can get into you know that's amazing
Martin I think that that is the best
place to to to finish our conversation
on thank you for everything you do a
pleasure I can't wait to be with you
again it's going to be amazing I can't
wait to I can't wait for all of us to be
at the world and people take your queue
you know get your tickets I'm going to
do my plug and uh and come meet us at
the symbolic world at the end of
February we are all excited to see you
there so thanks I want to invite you all
to the very first symbolic World Summit
over 3 days we will finally meet in real
time in real space and everyone from
this little corner of the internet will
be there to explore the theme of
reclaiming the cosmic image of course I
will be speaking but there will also be
Martin Shaw who is an amazing
mythographer ER father Steven D young of
Lord of spirit Fame there will be
Richard Roland from the universal
history series Vesper Stamper Nicholas
kotar and Neil deg grade that you've all
seen on my channel here and there for
entertainment we have everyone's
favorite apocalyptic band The One and
Only dirt po Robins this event will be
the chance of a lifetime to capture and
embrace our current moment so join us
from February 29th to March 2nd 2024 in
Tarpon spings Florida visit the symbolic
world.com Summit for more information
and I will see you
there their boards to pin the wings and
bodies of our God